bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au c
es je suis avec ganis la société blade
qui a un produit qui s'appelle shadow un
produit super intéressant en or die
dématérialisée au colorado
[Musique]
ces ados c'est simplement le premier pc
haut de gamme qui est entièrement
accessible par le cloud
le principe c'est que au lieu d'avoir
tous les trois ans on a habituellement
une grosse de son bureau qui chauffe qui
vont la place qu'ils consomment
énormément d'électricité
nous on a décidé de mettre tous ses
composants dans un datacenter et d'y
accéder par une simple connexion
internet à partir de la quatrième place
est d'accord alors je pose la question
tout à l'heure en europe mais 15 megabit
par seconde cela correspond à quoi ça
correspond à l'adsl moyen en france à
peu près à l'illiade et les zones que
vraiment il ya des comptes comprennent
deux collections d'années dans
l'ensemble de la france est très bien
desservi
on a 80 % du marché qui est aujourd'hui
une connexion très haut débit
on a vraiment aucun problème sur le
marché français reste ça veut dire que
j'ai un bottier avec nos dématérialisée
j'ai un clavier une souris un écran
alors l'une des particularités c'est
effectivement chez chalonnais
développeurs boîtier ce boîtier il
permet simplement en fait de connecter
un écran un clavier une souris et la
connexion internet est de remplacer
complètement la tour de l'ordinateur
mais au delà de la possibilité d'un
ordinateur les boîtiers
on propose alors des applications sur
windows contre mac os et sur android qui
permet de se connecter à shadow donc ce
soit sur un laptop un des stocks sur une
tablette sur un smartphone
ou même une smarttv android ça
fonctionne exactement comme
l'application netflix à dire on lance
son app et on arrive sur son bureau
windows ou directement sur le dernier
jeu qu'on avait lancé en fait 105 en
fait on a toujours accès à cette machine
vous l'êtes un ordinateur complet qui
était le vôtre
et au sur lequel on peut lancer ces jeux
utiliser photoshop la 3d n'importe
quelle application et qui depuis
n'importe quelle image
donc le point fort c'est effectivement
on a cette machine puissante
dématérialisée le point négatif c'est
que le jour où internet est coupé
màj suffit de sortir son téléphone et
aussi des lecteurs en cas d un peu le
trac la cage et ça veut dire qu'on est
vraiment multiples appareils exactement
c'est vraiment une solution qui est
complètement multi à bail
c'est un moyen d'accéder à sa machine
quelles que soient les conditions
aujourd'hui et ça permet d' alors non
seulement ce déserteur on aime conduire
à ce que l'hyper puissance
aujourd'hui c'est avec une carte
graphique nvidia haut de gamme dédié à
on offre voilà
vous y pensez vraiment une machine
capable de faire tourner tous les
derniers jeux
dutra il propose également des trucs
c'est très gamer comme la 4k
invité de faire du 144 sont
soulagé mais en plus de ça une des
particularité d'avoir
un pc dans le cloud comme le sais quoi à
chaque nouvelle génération de cartes
graphiques qui va sortir on changera les
cartes graphiques directement dans nos
serveurs censure couple aux utilisateurs
adorent toujours sur le même le même
forfait snow porte aujourd'hui son nom
à 30 euros par mois
l'engagement d'armées on aura toujours
accès à une machine qui sera le concept
c'est ça c'est de ne jamais jamais
jamais avoir d'obsolescence toujours une
machine sera au même niveau de
performance
même si non
4 puis 2 cartes graphiques et bien pas
besoin d'en racheter avec sa nounou
retrouve la machine hôte elle avait un
batîment génial alors la question que je
me pose c'est donc tu me dis on mise sur
une version ordinateur les sur un
windows
ouais tout à pc windows 10 mandats
il est livré sans aucun la donne est un
cri racheté il ya un petit bien vers le
suspense avait aucun problème mais tout
le reste est exactement comme un décès
qui est ce que le lot s est voulu
rassurant fonction des mises à jour 2 me
soit clair on est en bas oubangui post
condat roues ont perdu des mises à jour
dont 2
j'imagine que microsoft comme sur les
deux condamnations se dresse composeront
gratuite
nouvelle version dit si un jour il ya
windows pc ça
automatiquement accessibles
alors ça veut dire que quand on est sur
son ordination ordi sur un ring of death
metal et sur un smartphone par exemple
bon ça alors qu ici on nous montre que
windows est ce qu'on a vraiment sauvé sa
place après avoir comme unique à
l'international et en france
on a commencé un petit peu à communiquer
au delà de au delà de ça et est-ce qu'on
a dévoilé un
l'automne dernier quand on était
conférence de presse à paris je
t'apprends rien de plus tenté par
téléphone c'est une petite internet pour
les appeler à l'opinion
je pensais c'est justement sur ce matin
au lieu d'accéder à windows complet
d'avoir l'interface de windows est pas
agréable
on a tout simplement une interface qui
fait pour accéder directement à ces
lieux donc ce soir à des jeux vidéos de
la musique des films des photos d
accéder directement en un clic voilà il
est vrai que cela directement il décida
d'aller au delà de l'interface de
microsoft qui est pas fait pour
une utilisation smartphones
et composer vraiment la même expérience
on peut imaginer lançait donc
le dernier congrès d'heure directement
depuis son téléphone
d'accord le dernier tomb raider tu peux
jouer dessus directement dans ta
vraiment un
suivi tout est ensuite utilisables
depuis cinquante ans exactement fait
l'expérience est la même quel que soit
le dj sur lequel on est connecté
tu me disais un forfait à 30 euros par
mois avec un engagement dame en écoute
qu'est ce qu'on a comme fournit encore
chez vous il ya à 34,95 pas moi
avec un revers de 3 mois 44 95 15
environ un mois
et le boîtier dont qui est vendu
séparément il est bon goût 119 95
en location à 7,95 question va être
qu'est ce qui se passe il ya quelqu'un
au bout de cette période d'engagement
quand tu lis pas les goûts des données
qu'il a ce qu'il peut les récupérer ou
achetés à bord la première chose qu'il
fait c'est toutes ces données ont les
publier sur internet uniquement dans
leur dit pourquoi vous avait résilié
très mauvaise idée alors pourquoi non là
on leur en laisse à nos utilisateurs la
possibilité soit qu'ils ont 30 jours
pour
en gros une fois que la machine est
coupée ils ont encore 30 jours pour
récupérer les données sur un serveur et
après c'est assez
si jamais une demande de l'état
directement dans l'affairé
les prix peuvent même être assez leurs
machines de même directement ce qui va
alors du coup où est-ce qu'on peut
retrouver tout ça sur votre site sur
l'arn acide adressé shadowprotect hockey
qu'on est également présent sur facebook
sur château des confessions sur tous les
biens dans 10 contre twitter
un compte français et anglais est une
particularité
fondée sur une communauté très gamer
jugé que cette discorde qui est très
très bien qui permet d'avoir un lien
direct avec notre communauté on a créé
plus de personnes aujourd'hui sur dix
porte
avec l'équipe et avec lesquels en
échange au quotidien sur la environ du
produit
on est vraiment une boîte qui prône un
immense transparence on parle de tous
les problèmes pour en compte deux
tout le développement
notre quotidien régulièrement avec notre
communauté
ok cool en tous cas merci beaucoup merci
je vous inviterai de laisser des
commentaires est ce que vous connaissiez
déjà shadow est ce que vous êtes gamer
est ce que ça pourrait vous intéresser
il ya un engouement sur youtube donc je
pense qu'effectivement pour le court on
a vraiment des personnes trop
potentiellement intéressés qu'ils
connaissent déjà probablement marqué ma
tout ça en commentaire il évite bien
évidemment a blessé des pousse à vous
abonner à la chaîne on reste connectés
parce qu'on va parler toujours plus
d'entreprises françaises innovantes
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]